alors trouvez tous ceux de valérie plan
mairesse de montréal et marc demers
maire de laval bonsoir à vous deux
lanceurs madame drolet madame pas tu
veux commencer avec vous vous avez dit
je veux des engagements clairs le flou
on n'en veut pas les avez vous trouvés
clair aujourd'hui ben écoutez
oui mais en même temps c'est loin de ce
que l'on souhaite c'est à dire qu'il va
y avoir des jours entre
les est-ce que c'est des armes d'assaut
ou est-ce que dc des armes de poing et
je pense que c'est bien seul problème
c'est quand on commence à vouloir faire
une distinction alors que nous ce qu'on
demande les maires et les mairesses
parce que c'est sur nos territoires que
ça se passe on la voit la détresse on la
voit l'augmentation de la violence ce
qu'on veut c'est que les armes de poing
et dassault soit prohibé qu'elles soient
réglementées pour que ça soit pas banal
que ça soit pas qu'on puisse vraiment
contre et de façon efficace la la la la
criminalité et les groupes criminalisés
qui utilisent les armes à feu et ça ça
veut dire prohibées mais ça veut dire
mieux contrôler les frontières
d'investir massivement pour mieux les
protéger monsieur demers vous êtes un
maire vous êtes annoncé policiers aussi
les armes vous savez ce que si vous
savez les dégâts que sa cause et ça fait
des ravages aussi dans votre ville
pourquoi c'est important pour vous que
les chefs de persil
légifère mais différemment c'était ce
soit beaucoup plus strict avec les armes
de poing
effectué par
les armes de poing pour être contrôlés
beaucoup mieux accepter que ça pourrait
être disponible seulement des clubs de
tir où l'environnement est contrôlé mais
ce après une législation pièce sinon nos
services de police ne peuvent pas
intervenir oui à des enjeux d'argent
nous on a réagi dès le 28 à 25 ou on a
mis un point 2 millions à venir à nice
il ya eu à plaindre avec la marque et à
monsieur stéphane bohli ip directeur
cerveau à paris mais ce n'est pas je
suis assez contente pas nos frontières
été d un grand attrait et les dix
premiers je vous dirais je fais une
analogie les armes à feu sont un peu
le virus par laquelle la violence se
propage et on sait jusqu'à quel point à
l'heure actuelle il faut contrôler les
choses madame plantes monsieur trudeau
il visait de l'argent j'en ai les villes
ont justement demandé on veut leur
donner les pouvoirs de légiférer mais
c'est parce que vous voulez ben non
parce qu'en fait j'ai de la misère à
comprendre cette logique où tout d'un
coup ce serait une gestion par
territoire alors qu'on sait très bien
que la criminalité et les armes sont en
pleine circulation d'une ville à l'autre
mais également d'une province à l'autre
et c'est là où pour moi je m'explique
mal cette difficulté qu'ont les chefs
politiques à vraiment prendre un
engagement 10 ans ceux qui veulent aller
chasser ça va mieux on vous avez droit
de le faire mais que le code criminel
soit adapté qu'on protège mieux nos
frontières puis oui de l'argent pour
faire de la prévention absolument mais
ce qu'il faut envoyer ce message car
comme quoi au canada ça ne sera jamais
comme les états unis on va pas banaliser
cette violence là on va en faire une
priorité et c'est là où pour moi ça
manque encore de danse que les
différents chefs nous disent et encore
une fois il ne parle pas des armes de
poing mais essentiellement des armes
d'assaut mais surtout m comment vous la
comprenez vous cette hésitation cette
frilosité des chefs de partis on a quoi
l'on ne perde la vie des hommes ont eu
peur l'association des chaleurs et
qu'ils ne cèdent des chasseurs pardon et
qu'on donne un mot d'ordre de pauvreté
pour nous qu'est ce qui empêche les
chefs de partir très vite de ne pas
franchir ne pas vous leur demandez
tranché et puis je ne vois aucune raison
de
vous avez probablement touché au point
sur le point sensible c'est de perdre
des voix mais sa part le courage
politique c'est la sécurité des citoyens
qui est par jeu présentement et demain
on parle souvent de main mais les armes
aux beaucoup d'autres problèmes que
juste les moeurs uniquement des moeurs
des agressions sexuelles les enlèvement
et séquestration énormément de crime et
mais par quel policier qui a oeuvré dans
ce domaine la route alors le besoin de
contrôler les contrôles voire d'années
des renseignements pouvoir permettre des
suivis sur les arts et dames 1 le but
c'est de plus mais ces situations là
est-ce que non je me plante là dedans de
région compte une ville
vraiment je ne pense aux jeux parce
qu'il nous certaines des informations
inédites de vouloir mettre par exemple
les chasseurs en opposition avec les
problématiques avec la montée de la
violence moi je pense que ça ses
soutiens des problèmes majeurs mais je
vais vous dire tout à l'heure la
question vous poser je veux juste
ajouter un élément c'est que tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on va pas s'attaquer
à la racine du problème parce que
présentement nous les policiers ce qui
nous est si à chaque fois qu'on allait
venir une arme c'est un indice qui
nouvelle qui rendent qui circulent c'est
comme un coup d'épée dans l'eau alors un
moment donné il ya une situation une
augmentation de 80 % en dix ans le
nombre de l'utilisation des armes à feu
c'est un fait c'est des données réelles
il faut se poser la question dans quelle
société ce qu'on veut vivre qui moi
j'aime penser qu'on est capable de
s'attaquer à la racine du problème et
non pas juste donner de l'argent pour
gérer le territoire puis les impacts
négatifs dont monsieur demers parlait
oui monsieur demers ce qu'on entend le
chef conservateur monsieur autour lui
une approche plus on va être dur envers
le kremlin avec des peines ici on va
s'attaquer aux gangs de rue
si vous aviez monsieur o'toole devant
vous vous auriez envie de lui dire quoi
écoutez j'ai couvert plusieurs scènes de
décès s'installe le crime dans des
suicides être désactivée ils sont aussi
difficiles à gérer l'eau et j'ai
l'impression que si les décideurs
avaient été confrontés à de telles
situations là il hésitera même pas
bon il reste maintenant que l'autre
option que monsieur trudeau le met sur
la table c'est de dire d'un côté
d'argent ça peut être n'ont pas géré par
ville mais par province alors déjà on
vient de monter d'un étage madame plante
est ce que ce début de solution ça
témoin aujourd'hui le message que je
porte c'est que on s'attend à plus on
s'attend du courage politique j'aimerais
encore une fois rappeler qu'elle a
raison pour lesquelles on voulait à
palleville s'occuper du contrôle des
armes à feu c'est justement parce que
les armes n'ont pas de frontières et
qu'est ce qui se passe si par exemple à
montréal on les contrôle mais que dans
une autre ville pour différentes raisons
ce n'est pas les mêmes règles ce n'est
pas les mêmes effectifs ou encore les
mêmes ressources qu'est ce qui va se
passer au niveau inter provinciale moi
c'est ma préoccupation c'est toujours à
la même idée de devenir à la racine du
problème et de bannir les armes de poing
des armes d'assaut n'empêchera jamais
les chasseurs de chasser mais ça va pour
empêcher une prochaine polytechnique un
prochain d'asthme c'est de cela dont il
est question à ce moment vous devez
merci beaucoup d'avoir préciser votre
pensée et votre message avec nous
merci merci